the girl and the ice cream truck
an original tale by the fablecottage.com
a girl sits at her bedroom window
looking down at the street
she is waiting for summer
[Music]
she wants to eat ice cream and go
swimming
she wants picnics and strawberries
she is tired of winter jackets and
gloves
she is tired of gray skies and snow
her mother says that summer is far away
her father says that more snow is coming
still she sits at the window waiting for
some sign that summer has arrived
just then she sees an ice cream truck
driving down the street
an ice cream truck that must mean it's
summer now
squeals
she runs to her closet and puts on her
bathing suit and her summer hat
she runs down the stairs and out the
door and
crunch
she looks down and sees her bare feet in
the icy grass
but
he says confused
she looks up just in time to see the ice
cream truck turn the corner
and pull into the auto repair shop
moral don't draw a conclusion based on a
single observation
one ice cream truck does not make a
summer
[Music]
good